Russian soldier a Marine was recently
killed in Syria he was a member of a
helicopter crew that was attacked by
militants and we went to the funeral it
was a oppressive affair there was a
military fans serving members of the
Armed Forces veterans a thousand or more
members of the local community his name
was Alexander Paz Enosh his family was
there too of course he had two young
children
you probably remember the story the
helicopter was fired on by a group of
militants who also film what they were
doing they then uploaded their pictures
and they were shared worldwide and I
think people in this country were
genuinely surprised shocked even by what
had happened you know on Russian state
television every night people are told
by the presenters that Russian forces
are engaged in a virtuous war in Syria
and that their armed forces are
technologically advanced the dangers are
made to seem remote like specks of dust
on a video screen the depths of quaza
niche and another airman called peshkov
who died when his fighter jet was
brought down by the turks their deaths
could not be ignored they couldn't be
swept away and both men have been given
full military funerals they've been
buried as national heroes but you know
that's not always the case in Russia
we're just coming back now from the
western part of the country near the
border with Belarus where we heard about
another funeral the man called for door
dural off he it's believed was a member
of a special operations group of
Spetsnaz unit and his friends online
were saying that he too was killed in
Syria we've just come from his home
village and we were told that it is
common knowledge there that he was
killed again in Syria but he had a very
low-key
the funeral and the Ministry of Defense
the Russian Ministry of Defence refused
to comment about his death they won't
tell us where he died they won't tell us
how he died and we have seen this sort
of thing before
last year in Ukraine it's widely thought
that Russian soldiers died and then were
were quietly buried they were secretly
buried and I think in this case it
raises a number of significant questions
to start with how many Russian citizens
have died in Syria the official death
toll is three but is it more and
secondly I would Russian people feel how
would they react if they believe that
more people are dying than the official
numbers